now that we know what an angle is let's
think about how we can measure them and
we already hinted at one way to think
about the measure of an angle in the
last video where we said look this angle
xyz seems more open than angle bac so
maybe the measure of angle xyz should be
larger than the angle of bac and that is
exactly the way we think about the
measures of angles but what i want to do
in this video is come up with an exact
way to measure an angle so what i've
drawn over here is a little bit of a of
a half circle and it looks very similar
to a tool that you can buy your local
school supply store to measure angles so
this is actually a little bit of a
drawing of a protractor
of a protractor and what we do in
something like a protractor and you can
even construct one with a piece of paper
is we've taken a half circle right here
and we've divided it into 180 sections
and each of these marks marks 10 of
those sections and what you do for any
given angle is you put one of the sides
of the angle so each of the rays of an
angle are considered one of its sides so
you you put the vertex you put the
vertex of the angle at the center
at the center of this half circle or if
you're dealing with an actual protractor
at the center of that protractor and
then you put one side along the
zero mark
you put one side along the zero mark so
i'm going to redo this
i'm going to redraw this angle right
over here at the center of this
protractor so if we said this is y
then z goes right over here and then the
other ray
the other ray ray y z or ray y x in this
circumstance will go roughly in that
direction and so it is pointing it is
pointing on the protractor to the let's
see this looks like this is the 70th
section this is the 80th section so
maybe this is i would say i would guess
the 77th section
so this is pointing to 77 right over
here and so when we measure an angle so
we could say the measure of angle xyz
assuming that i drew it the right way
right over here we could say the measure
of
the measure of angle x
y z sometimes i'll just say angle x y z
is equal to but this is a little bit
more formal the measure of angle x y z
is equal to
77 and what we do is we call each of
these each of these little sections we
call them degrees so it's equal to 77
77 sometimes it's written like that a
little a little
and the same way you would write degrees
for the temperature outside so you could
write 77 degrees like that or you could
actually write out the word right over
there so each of these sections are a
degree so we're measuring in degrees and
i want to be clear degrees aren't the
only way to measure angles really
anything that measures the openness so
when you go into trigonometry you'll
learn that you can measure angles not
only in degrees but also using something
called radians but i'll leave that to
another day so let's measure this other
angle angle
bac
so once again i'll put a at the center
and then ac
i'll put along i'll put along the zero
degree
edge of this half circle or of this
protractor and then i'll point a b in
the well assuming that i'm drawing it
exactly the way that it's over there
normally instead of moving the angle you
could actually move the protractor to
the angle
so you it would look something like that
and you could see that it's pointing to
right about well let's just say right
about the 30 degree the 30 degree mark
so we can say that the measure of angle
bac is equal to 30 degrees and so you
can look just straight up from
evaluating this these numbers that 77
degrees is clearly
larger than 30 degrees and so it is a
larger angle which makes sense because
it is a more it is a more open angle and
in general there's a couple of
interesting angles to think about if you
have zero degree angle you actually have
something that's just a closed angle it
really is just a ray at that point as
you get larger and larger or as you get
more and more open
you eventually get to a point where one
of the rays is completely straight up
and down while the other one is left
right so you could imagine an angle that
looks like this
you could imagine an angle that looks
like this where one ray goes straight up
down like that
and the other ray goes straight right
left or you could imagine something like
an angle that looks like this
where at least the way you're looking at
it doesn't one doesn't look straight up
down or one doesn't look straight right
left but if you rotate it
if you rotate it it would look just like
this thing right over here where one is
going straight up and down and one is
going straight right and left and you
can see from this from our measure right
over here that that gives us a 90 degree
angle which is very very it's a very
interesting angle it shows up many many
times in geometry and trigonometry and
there's a special word for a 90 degree
angle it is called a right angle so this
right over here assuming if you rotate
it around would look just like this we
would call this a right angle
right
right angle and there is a notation to
show that it's a right angle you draw a
little kind of part of a box right over
there and that tells us that this is
going exactly if you were to rotate it
exactly up and down while this is going
exactly right and left if you were to
rotate it properly or vice versa and
then as you go even wider you get wider
and wider and wider and wider until you
get all the way to a
to an angle that looks like this so you
can imagine an angle where
where the two rays in that angle form a
line
the two rays so let's say this is point
x this is point y
and this is point z you could call this
angle z
x y but it's really so open that it's
formed an actual line here z x and y are
collinear and what we have right over
here this is a 180 degree angle
or we should say the measure of angle z
x y
measure of angle z x y is 180 degrees
and you can actually go beyond that so
if you were to go all the way around the
circle so that you would get back to 360
degrees and then you could keep going
round and round and round and you see
you'll start to see a lot more of that
when you when you enter a trigonometry
class now there's one last or two last
things that i want to introduce in the
in this video is there are special words
and i'll talk about more types of angles
in the next video but if an angle is
less than 90 degrees if an angle is less
than 90 degrees so for example both of
these angles that we started our
discussion with are less than 90 degrees
we call them acute angles
acute
acute so anything so this is acute
so that is an acute angle
and that is an acute angle right over
here they are less than 90 degrees what
does a non-acute angle look like and
there's a word for it other than
non-acute well it would be more than 90
degrees so for example
let me do this in a color i haven't used
an angle that looks like this
and let me draw a little bit better than
that an angle that looks like this so
that's one of that's one side of the
angle or one of the rays and then that
i'll put the other one along the
baseline right over here clearly this is
larger than 90 degrees if i were to
approximate let's see that's 100 110 120
almost 130. so let's call that maybe 128
degree angle we call this an obtuse
angle
we call this an obtuse angle the way i
remember it is acute it's kind of a cute
angle it's nice and small if if i i
believe acute in in
either latin or greek or maybe both
means something like pin or sharp so
that's one way to think about it the the
an acute angle seems much sharper obtuse
i kind of imagine something that's
that's kind of lumbering and large and
so that's how i you know or you could
think it's it's not acute it's not nice
and small and pointy so that's one way
to think about it but these are just
general this is just general terminology
for different types of angles less than
90 degrees you have an acute angle at 90
degrees you have a right angle larger
than 90 degrees you have an obtuse angle
and then if you get all the way to 180
degrees your angle actually forms a line